Alice: 5秒
Alice: 5 seconds
Jake: 来
Jake: Here we go
Tasha: OK了
Tasha: Okay, done
Jake: 来录呀开始了吗
Jake: Are we recording? Has it started?
Alice:等一下
Alice: Wait a moment
Jake: 啊好好
Jake: Ah, okay
Jake: 那我们后边先看
Jake: Let's look at the back first
Alice:耶
Alice: Yay
Lucia: 啊开始了
Lucia: Ah, it started
Alice: 看这个好茂盛
Alice: Look at this, it's so lush
Lucia: 我说好的
Lucia: I know, right?
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh
Tasha: 他真好
Tasha: He's really nice
Jake: 好我们有很多东西
Jake: Okay, we have a lot of stuff
Jake: 稍等一下
Jake: Hold on a moment
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks
Alice: 这是别人那啥的
Alice: This is someone else's, uh
Alice:有门
Alice: There's a door
Tasha: 别人的庄园
Tasha: Someone else's estate
Alice:哎
Alice: Oh
Alice:啊 走下车吧
Alice: Ah, let's get off the car
Alice:哎
Alice: Oh
Alice: 东西没落上吗
Alice: Didn't forget anything, right?
Alice: 没有
Alice: Nope
Alice: 哎呦
Alice: Ouch
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm
Alice: 挤得好像
Alice: It's so crowded
Alice:巨沉
Alice: Super heavy
Lucia: 我们俩一起
Lucia: Let's do it together
Lucia: 哇这个真的好重
Lucia: Wow, this is really heavy
Lucia: 对，咱俩一起
Lucia: Yeah, let's do it together
Lucia: 要不可能里面饮料比较多
Lucia: Maybe there are a lot of drinks inside
Lucia: 啊对
Lucia: Ah, yeah
Alice:怎么撒了
Alice: Why is it spilling?
Lucia: 可以把这个这个
Lucia: You can put this, this
Tasha: 小心点
Tasha: Be careful
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Tasha: 他他的摄像头
Tasha: His camera
Jake: 哎呀头确实疼
Jake: Oh, my head really hurts
Jake:还有
Jake: Also
Alice: 还有我们的司机  跟蒜苗
Alice: And our driver, with garlic sprouts.
Tasha: 我我
Tasha: Me, me.
Jake: 好谢谢谢谢你
Jake: Okay, thank you, thank you.
Alice:呵呵
Alice: Hehe.
Lucia: 没没没掉吧
Lucia: Did it fall?
Tasha: 哎蒜
Tasha: Oh, garlic.
Alice: 哎呀这个不是我们的吧
Alice: Oh no, this isn't ours, right?
Tasha: 不是都不是了
Tasha: No, none of it is.
Alice: 哦走吧
Alice: Oh, let's go.
Alice:嗯熏人
Alice: Hmm, it's suffocating.
Alice: 哎其实我们隔着这个也能够一把
Alice: Actually, we can grab it from here too.
Alice: 是吧
Alice: Right?
Alice: 我看看
Alice: Let me see.
Alice:不好意思啊
Alice: Sorry about that.
Alice: 我觉得这个小紫花也可以
Alice: I think this little purple flower works too.
Alice: 你看挺好看的
Alice: Look, it's quite pretty.
Tasha: 是的嘞
Tasha: Yes, it is.
Alice:他把我这个偷
Alice: He stole my...
Alice: 呃拿花
Alice: Uh, took the flower.
Alice:呵呵 摘花
Alice: Hehe, picking flowers.
Tasha: 给记录下来了
Tasha: Got it on record.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
Alice: 没关系这个数据就是
Alice: It's okay, this data is just...
Alice: 狗狗碎碎的
Alice: All over the place.
Tasha: 呃前面一个吧
Tasha: Uh, the one in front.
Alice:前面到
Alice: Up front.
Alice:你这个小花装起来好好看啊
Alice: These flowers you arranged look so nice.
Alice:录下来吧
Alice: Let's record it.
Alice: 们的房子不是绿色的吗
Alice: Isn't our house green?
Alice:是吗
Alice: Right?
Tasha: 蓝绿色
Tasha: Blue-green.
Alice:这个吗
Alice: This one?
Alice: 这个颜色吗
Alice: This color?
Tasha: 前面这个
Tasha: The one in front.
Tasha: 但感觉又走错了
Tasha: But it feels like we're lost.
Alice: 你们不应该是从那个吗
Alice: Weren't you supposed to come from there?
Lucia: 哎呦
Lucia: Oh no.
Alice:额
Alice: Uh.
Lucia: 是的但好像比刚那个稍微好一点点
Lucia: Yeah, but it seems a bit better than before.
Lucia: 走咱加快步伐
Lucia: Let's speed up.
Jake: 极限一换一
Jake: Extreme one-for-one
Alice: 这个给我吧
Alice: Give this to me
Lucia: 谢谢您辛苦了
Lucia: Thank you for your hard work
Jake: 健身我是两年前健
Jake: I started working out two years ago
Jake: 我到新加坡之后就不健了
Jake: After I moved to Singapore, I stopped
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake: 因为
Jake: Because
Jake:你
Jake: You
Alice:右右右 右
Alice: Right, right, right
Jake: 右边右边啊
Jake: To the right, to the right
Lucia: 因为工作比较忙嘛
Lucia: Because work is quite busy
Jake: 因为健身房有点远
Jake: Because the gym is a bit far
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake: 就是作为一个p人吧
Jake: As a lazy person
Jake: 就健身房他不在楼底下我应该很难去
Jake: If the gym isn't downstairs, it's hard for me to go
Lucia: 任何东西不离我很近我一般都很难去
Lucia: Anything that's not close to me, I generally find hard to go to
Tasha: 应该把小米装
Tasha: Should put the Xiaomi oven
Tasha: 装小米烤箱的那个袋子带着的
Tasha: In the bag that comes with the Xiaomi oven
Alice:小狗 嘬嘬嘬嘬嘬嘬
Alice: Puppy, come here, come here
Tasha: 那个大袋子啊
Tasha: That big bag
Alice:额
Alice: Uh
Jake: 还有个线是吧
Jake: There's a wire, right?
Alice: 那个小狗
Alice: That puppy
Alice: 朝它嘬嘬嘬
Alice: Call it over
Alice: 他就他就过来看你
Alice: It'll come to you
Tasha: 然后你也不喂他吃的
Tasha: And then you don't feed it
Alice: 这个嘬嘬嘬
Alice: This sound
Alice: 像他喝奶的声音
Alice: Sounds like it's drinking milk
Alice: 所以他就过来了
Alice: So it comes over
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Alice: 要不然你跟我换一个
Alice: How about we trade?
Tasha: 没关系走少了一个人就是很困难啊
Tasha: It's okay, it's difficult with one less person
Alice: Sure
Lucia: 我们的有有密码吗
Lucia: Do we have a password?
Jake: 有密码但是我记不住
Jake: There is a password, but I can't remember it
Lucia: 嗯哈哈
Lucia: Hmm, haha
Lucia: 那您来说
Lucia: Then you say it
Jake: 我要查一下手机
Jake: I need to check my phone
Jake: 这个时候手机如果能告诉你
Jake: If the phone could tell you at this time
Tasha: 但我记住了
Tasha: But I remembered it
Tasha: 不是这么说的吗
Tasha: Isn't that what you said?
Lucia: 问一下星瑞
Lucia: Ask Xingrui.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh dear.
Jake: 哦但他说的好像是但他记住了
Jake: Oh, but he said it like that, he remembered it.
Lucia: 啊这个好像是
Lucia: Ah, this seems right.
Jake: 哈哈我没有记住
Jake: Haha, I didn't remember it.
Lucia: 这个要是有语音功能就好了
Lucia: If only this had a voice function.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 问问他
Lucia: Ask him.
Lucia: 哎呦
Lucia: Oh my.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 我发现这个摄像头会发出彩虹光哎
Lucia: I noticed this camera gives off rainbow lights.
Jake: 是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake: 再再再摁一次那个3
Jake: Press the 3 again.
Alice:3没摁上
Alice: The 3 didn't press.
Jake: 那3再摁一下
Jake: Then press the 3 again.
Lucia: 那我我
Lucia: Then I, I...
Jake:三三
Jake: Three, three.
Lucia: 怎样能把它删掉
Lucia: How can I delete it?
Jake: 不就不用
Jake: No need to.
Jake: 不用重来
Jake: No need to restart.
Jake: 就就是你直接重来就行
Jake: Just restart directly.
Jake: 他就算最后一位
Jake: He'll be the last one.
Lucia: 925
Lucia: 925.
Jake:对是
Jake: Yes, right.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 我们一块来吧
Lucia: Let's do this together.
Lucia: 这真的太重了
Lucia: This is really heavy.
Jake:不是我们就这什么呀到底
Jake: What are we doing exactly?
Alice: 这是他的帽子
Alice: This is his hat.
Lucia: 哎这个怎么
Lucia: Hey, how do you...
Lucia: 不咋了这门不太灵活
Lucia: Why is this door not very flexible?
Alice:呵呵
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 我们就把这个密码大声的输出来
Jake: Let's just loudly input the password.
Jake: 这真的合适
Jake: Is this really appropriate?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake: 你怕这个邻居听不见是吧
Jake: Afraid the neighbors can't hear it, right?
Jake: 嗯大家好
Jake: Um, hi everyone.
Jake: 我们的门禁是
Jake: Our door access is...
Lucia: 现在就放一下
Lucia: Let's just put it now.
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Oh no.
Lucia: 一会大家一起收拾一收拾
Lucia: Let's tidy up together later.
Tasha: 哇哇
Tasha: Wow wow.
Katrina:  赛博世纪
Katrina: Cyber century.
Alice: 哎呀呀呀
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Lucia: 给拍一个
Lucia: Take a picture.
Alice:额
Alice: Ugh.
Tasha: 往里面放一点
Tasha: Put it a bit inside.
Tasha: 哇这个真的来放不了了
Tasha: Wow, this really can't fit anymore.
Katrina:  真的很离谱
Katrina: It's really ridiculous.
Lucia: 真的很赛博
Lucia: It's really cyber.
Alice: 他可能会放地上
Alice: He might put it on the floor.
Lucia: 您的卧室真的很赛博
Lucia: Your bedroom is really cyber.
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Jake: 晚上就是这个样子
Jake: It looks like this at night.
Jake: 因为怕这个关掉之后数据就倒不过去
Jake: Because if I turn it off, the data won't transfer over.
Alice:累死了
Alice: So tired.
Jake: 对得开着
Jake: Yeah, it has to stay on.
Jake: 然后突然惊醒的看一眼哦
Jake: Then suddenly wake up and check, oh.
Jake: 还在传哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: It's still transferring, hahaha.
Alice:这好好看
Alice: This looks so good.
Lucia: 我可以在你的小桌子上玩2077吗
Lucia: Can I play 2077 on your little table?
Lucia: 哈哈沉浸式玩游戏
Lucia: Haha, immersive gaming.
Jake: 哈
Jake: Ha.
Jake: 是呵
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  我要记一下我们还有什么东西没买
Katrina: I need to note down what we haven't bought yet.
Katrina:  笔呢
Katrina: Where's the pen?
Tasha: 我们先把要放进冰箱的挑出来
Tasha: Let's pick out what needs to go into the fridge first.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Tasha: 把
Tasha: Put...
Katrina:  这个笔呢
Katrina: This pen, where is it?
Katrina:  谁看见了
Katrina: Did anyone see it?
Jake: 笔我带上去了我
Jake: I took the pen upstairs.
Alice:好看
Alice: Looks good.
Jake: 再带下来
Jake: I'll bring it back down.
Lucia: 哪瓶水是我的来着
Lucia: Which bottle of water is mine?
Lucia: 我们应该没
Lucia: We probably didn't...
Lucia: 我应该没
Lucia: I should...
Lucia: 拿出去喝两口
Lucia: Take it out for a sip.
Alice: 我想喝口水
Alice: I want a drink of water.
Alice: 没有没开的水
Alice: Is there any unopened water?
Tasha: 呦这这对
Tasha: Oh, this pair...
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Lucia: 噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔
Lucia: Dun dun dun dun dun dun dun!
Tasha: 嗯嗯没事看看
Tasha: Hmm, it's fine. Just take a look.
Tasha: 咦是吧
Tasha: Hmm, right?
Lucia: 什么情况啊
Lucia: What's going on?
Jake: 啊这个要不砍了吧
Jake: Ah, how about we cut this?
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This...
Lucia: 对他好像打不开
Lucia: Yeah, it seems it can't be opened.
Jake: 买一个大刀把它给剪了
Jake: Get a big knife and cut it.
Lucia: 哦开了开了
Lucia: Oh, it's open now.
Lucia: 有点紧那个
Lucia: It's a bit tight.
Lucia: 记得
Lucia: Remember...
Jake:这个
Jake: This...
Tasha: 水果水果放一起
Tasha: Fruits go together.
Tasha: 蔬菜放一起
Tasha: Vegetables go together.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Lucia: 没开封的饮料其实可以先放在外面
Lucia: Unopened drinks can actually be kept outside for now.
Lucia: 就是咱们现在因为东西比较多就不要
Lucia: Since we have a lot of stuff now, let's not...
Alice: 楼上是不是还有冰箱
Alice: Isn't there a fridge upstairs?
Katrina:  那我把对饮料放楼上去
Katrina: Then I'll put the drinks upstairs.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Jake:对楼上也有冰箱
Jake: Yeah, there's a fridge upstairs too.
Lucia: 楼上有个冰箱
Lucia: There's a fridge upstairs.
Jake: 等一下先先别
Jake: Wait a minute, don't...
Lucia: 我们先把先把必须放冰箱的放进去
Lucia: Let's first put in what needs to be refrigerated.
Jake:先把冰给放一下
Jake: Put the ice in first.
Lucia: 然后再考虑别的
Lucia: Then we can think about other things.
Lucia: 冰
Lucia: Ice.
Jake:就是要放冰冻的
Jake: Yeah, things that need to be frozen.
Jake: 冷冻的哦
Jake: Frozen, okay?
Katrina:  还有个蓝莓是吗
Katrina: There's also some blueberries, right?
Katrina:  冷冻啊这个是需要放冰箱的
Katrina: Frozen, yeah, these need to be in the fridge.
Tasha: 还有一盒草莓呢
Tasha: And there's a box of strawberries.
Alice:冷
Alice: Cold.
Tasha: 啊哦在这
Tasha: Ah, it's here.
Tasha: 哦吓我一跳
Tasha: Oh, it scared me.
Katrina:  这个是必须放冰箱的
Katrina: This needs to be kept in the fridge.
Lucia: 这个是放冷藏室
Lucia: This goes in the fridge.
Lucia: 冷冻室啊
Lucia: The freezer, right?
Katrina: 冷藏吧
Katrina: Fridge, I think.
Katrina:  冷冻冷藏
Katrina: Freezer or fridge.
Alice:冷藏
Alice: Fridge.
Alice: 冻冻这个冷藏有0度吗
Alice: Freezing this, does the fridge get to 0 degrees?
Alice: 我怎么感觉这温度不太够
Alice: I feel like the temperature isn't enough.
Katrina:  我把饮料挤入哎
Katrina: I'll squeeze in the drinks.
Jake: 哎你们不是有那个测温的吗
Jake: Hey, don't you have a thermometer?
Jake: 呵没有用吗
Jake: Doesn't it work?
Tasha: 要要干嘛
Tasha: For what?
Jake: 测冰箱多少度
Jake: To check the fridge temperature.
Lucia: 万一不够的话
Lucia: What if it's not enough?
Alice:应该也有
Alice: It should be.
Lucia: 那个肉也可以放冷冻室
Lucia: The meat can go in the freezer.
Lucia: 然后尽快吃
Lucia: And eat it soon.
Lucia: 只要它上面结的霜不要太多就行
Lucia: As long as there's not too much frost on it.
Tasha: 这放两瓶鲜牛奶刚刚好
Tasha: Putting two bottles of fresh milk fits perfectly.
Tasha: 这个可以拿出来了
Tasha: This can be taken out.
Alice: 鲜牛奶
Alice: Fresh milk.
Katrina: 这
Katrina: This.
Katrina:  这这个扔了吧
Katrina: Let's throw this away.
Tasha: 这个可以拿出来
Tasha: This can be taken out.
Katrina:  烤鸭这个昨天晚上
Katrina: The roast duck from last night.
Tasha: 我天哪冰箱里面放菜说我不能接受
Tasha: Oh my, putting food in the fridge without saying, I can't accept it.
Katrina:  而且没有盖保鲜膜
Katrina: And it's not covered with cling film.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Katrina:  扔了吧
Katrina: Let's throw it away.
Jake: 丢吧来
Jake: Throw it away, come on.
Katrina:  这酒啥的我放二楼吧
Katrina: I'll put the alcohol on the second floor.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Sure.
Katrina:  我想这一楼先做饭是在一楼吧
Katrina: I think we should cook on the first floor first.
Alice: 是这样的
Alice: That's right.
Alice:哎呦对不起
Alice: Oh, sorry.
Lucia: 蛋要放冰箱吧应该
Lucia: Eggs should go in the fridge, right?
Lucia: 芒果
Lucia: Mangoes.
Jake:芒果
Jake: Mangoes.
Lucia: 芒果是用来做做甜品的时候用的吗
Lucia: Are the mangoes used for making desserts?
Jake: 呃好
Jake: Uh, okay.
Jake: 是吗芒果是给人
Jake: Really, are mangoes for people
Jake: 吃的还是
Jake: to eat or
Lucia: 对我也想
Lucia: Yeah, I also think
Tasha: 额做甜品的
Tasha: Uh, for making desserts.
Jake:做甜品
Jake: For making desserts.
Lucia: 那这个呢
Lucia: What about this?
Jake: 那为什么要6个呀
Jake: Then why do we need six?
Tasha: 我只是觉得6个比较划算
Tasha: I just thought six was more economical.
Jake: 哦我以为你数了6个人呢
Jake: Oh, I thought you counted six people.
Lucia: 呵一人一个
Lucia: Haha, one for each person.
Jake: 对哈哈哈
Jake: Right, hahaha.
Lucia: 呃今晚就把它吃掉
Lucia: Let's just eat them all tonight.
Jake:你说的特别的对
Jake: You're absolutely right.
Lucia: 那这个这个
Lucia: And this, this one.
Jake:和你说的65这个数字
Jake: And about that number 65 you mentioned,
Lucia: 这个菠萝是今天晚上吃的
Lucia: Is this pineapple for tonight?
Lucia: 还是要用的
Lucia: Or to be used?
Tasha: 呃今天晚上吃的啊
Tasha: Uh, it's for tonight.
Lucia: 呃那要不就放外面
Lucia: Then let's just leave it out.
Lucia: 反正今天晚上要吃
Lucia: Since we're eating it tonight anyway.
Jake: 我们点个外卖吧
Jake: Let's order some takeout.
Lucia: 好嘞
Lucia: Alright.
Jake:给给
Jake: Sure, sure.
Tasha: 还有一瓶鲜奶呢
Tasha: There's still a bottle of fresh milk.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:还需要
Alice: Do we still need
Alice: 还有肉吗
Alice: any more meat?
Tasha: 没有肉了啊
Tasha: No more meat.
Katrina:  还有虾滑
Katrina: There's still shrimp paste.
Katrina:  等一下还还有一瓶虾滑
Katrina: Wait, there's another bottle of shrimp paste.
Alice:呢来 虾滑要放底下
Alice: Here, shrimp paste goes at the bottom.
Tasha:还有底下那个
Tasha: And there's that thing at the bottom.
Lucia: 嗯哼
Lucia: Uh-huh.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Lucia: 西瓜
Lucia: Watermelon.
Tasha: 牛奶
Tasha: Milk.
Alice: 就是啊怎么只剩一个了
Alice: Yeah, why is there only one left?
Tasha: 哎怎么只剩一瓶牛奶了啊
Tasha: Hey, why is there only one bottle of milk left?
Lucia: 那那里那里那里还有一个袋子
Lucia: There, there, there’s another bag.
Jake:放进去了
Jake: Put it in.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Lucia: 我来拿吧
Lucia: I'll take it.
Tasha: 你
Tasha: You...
Jake:错了错了错了
Jake: Wrong, wrong, wrong.
Jake: 对不起对不起对不起对不起
Jake: Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Tasha: 放这的
Tasha: Put it here.
Tasha: 因为感觉这样子一定要放在一起
Tasha: Because I feel like it should be placed together.
Tasha: 就会很好看
Tasha: It will look nice.
Alice:好看
Alice: Looks nice.
Tasha: 对所以我一直在找他
Tasha: Yeah, so I've been looking for it.
Alice:蛋是不是放这
Alice: Should the eggs be placed here?
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Alice:这有个蛋篓
Alice: There's an egg basket here.
Lucia: 这里还有一盒蛋
Lucia: There's another box of eggs here.
Tasha: 这盒蛋是可食用蛋
Tasha: This box of eggs is edible.
Tasha: 可生吃蛋
Tasha: They can be eaten raw.
Alice: 这个
Alice: This...
Alice:放
Alice: Put...
Tasha: 直接这样吧
Tasha: Just put it like this.
Alice: 哇哦
Alice: Wow.
Alice:哎可以
Alice: Hey, that's fine.
Alice: 这底下我觉得可以利用一下
Alice: I think we can make use of the bottom here.
Tasha: 哎可以先放这
Tasha: Hey, we can put this here for now.
Jake: 你们在采购之前
Jake: Before you went shopping...
Alice:沉不沉
Alice: Is it heavy?
Jake: 有人仔细的看过冰箱吗
Jake: Did anyone take a good look at the fridge?
Katrina:  没有咋啦
Katrina: No, why?
Lucia: 但是需要的话
Lucia: But if needed...
Lucia: 咱们可以现在上仔细的看一下
Lucia: We can go take a close look now.
Lucia: 那个没用了的冰箱
Lucia: The unused fridge.
Lucia: 还没用到的冰箱啊
Lucia: The fridge we haven't used yet.
Jake: 额也不用也不用
Jake: Uh, no need, no need.
Jake: 就是就就
Jake: Just, just...
Jake: 你们其实也没有看冰箱
Jake: You guys actually didn't check the fridge.
Tasha: 一个问卷
Tasha: A questionnaire.
Jake: 大概也就知道怎么回事了是吗
Jake: So you roughly know what's going on, right?
Lucia: 呃怎么回事
Lucia: Uh, what's going on?
Jake:就是就是
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake: 就是大概
Jake: Like, approximately.
Jake: 呃我们装多少东西啊
Jake: Um, how much stuff are we packing?
Alice:这样
Alice: Like this.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 这个能放这吗
Tasha: Can this go here?
Lucia: 得一个估算吧
Lucia: We need an estimate, right?
Alice:放不下
Alice: It won't fit.
Jake: 可能有吧
Jake: Maybe it will.
Jake: 就当有吧
Jake: Let's assume it will.
Jake: 问题不大
Jake: It's not a big deal.
Lucia: 我们可以姑且认为他有
Lucia: We can assume it will fit.
Alice:竖着
Alice: Vertically.
Jake: 对对对就
Jake: Yeah, yeah, like that.
Lucia: 这还有两盒安佳稀奶油有一个
Lucia: There are two boxes of Anchor cream, one...
Alice:OK
Alice: OK.
Lucia: 这个也要放冰箱吧
Lucia: This also needs to go in the fridge, right?
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Alice: 可以可以
Alice: Yes, yes.
Tasha: 这些奶油
Tasha: These creams...
Alice:放这放这吧
Alice: Put them here, put them here.
Alice: 你那个塞不下了
Alice: Yours won't fit.
Alice: 你搁这吧
Alice: Put it here.
Tasha: 啊可是他应该放在那个区域
Tasha: Ah, but it should go in that section.
Alice: 没事
Alice: It's fine.
Tasha: 但奶油有三瓶
Tasha: But there are three bottles of cream.
Lucia: 哎三瓶吗
Lucia: Huh, three bottles?
Katrina:  这里面怎么感觉
Katrina: How does it feel inside?
Lucia: 哦哦还有一瓶耶
Lucia: Oh, there's another bottle!
Alice: 把它放这
Alice: Put it here.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Alice:另一瓶
Alice: The other bottle.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 这个先在这放一下吧
Lucia: Let's put this here for now.
Lucia: 如果不是今天晚上吃的就放到冰箱
Lucia: If we're not eating it tonight, put it in the fridge.
Alice:拿过来
Alice: Bring it here.
Jake: 吃什么呢
Jake: What are we eating?
Jake: 晚上吃什么呢
Jake: What are we eating tonight?
Lucia: 晚上吃什么呢
Lucia: What are we eating tonight?
Jake: 吃什么呢
Jake: What are we eating?
Jake: 烧烤哈哈
Jake: Barbecue haha
Tasha: 一定要记进去
Tasha: Make sure to write it down.
Tasha: 好就这样记
Tasha: Alright, just write it down like this.
Jake:饭呢
Jake: What about the food?
Jake: 盖浇饭
Jake: Rice with toppings.
Jake: 吉野家板面
Jake: Yoshinoya noodles.
Lucia: 我都可以
Lucia: I'm fine with anything.
Jake: 三文鱼
Jake: Salmon.
Jake:烤全鱼
Jake: Grilled whole fish.
Jake: 螺蛳粉
Jake: Snail rice noodles.
Lucia: 螺蛳粉咱们这个房间透气性好吗
Lucia: Is the ventilation in this room good for snail rice noodles?
Jake: 那确实不太好
Jake: Yeah, it's not really good.
Jake: 蟹黄拌饭
Jake: Crab roe rice.
Jake: 肉蟹堡
Jake: Crab burger.
Jake: 春饼
Jake: Spring pancake.
Tasha: 还有一盒草莓呢
Tasha: There's also a box of strawberries.
Lucia: 呃是不是在那里面
Lucia: Uh, is it in there?
Lucia: 没有吗
Lucia: No?
Lucia: 哎那那边那个也已经拿出来了
Lucia: Oh, that one over there has already been taken out.
Jake: 火锅底料
Jake: Hotpot base.
Lucia: 倒是还有一盒蓝莓不过
Lucia: There's still a box of blueberries though.
Tasha: 蓝莓放在这
Tasha: Put the blueberries here.
Lucia: 在这
Lucia: Here.
Tasha: 我嗯还还有一盒草莓呢
Tasha: I still have another box of strawberries.
Alice: 这只有一盒
Alice: There's only one box.
Katrina: 喏，那里
Katrina: Look, over there.
Lucia: 噢
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 天呐就跟瞎了一样
Tasha: Gosh, it's like we're blind.
Katrina:  是的是的哎
Katrina: Yes, yes, indeed.
Jake: 哎我们把这个灯开下来
Jake: Hey, let's turn on this light.
Jake: 可能就少瞎一点
Jake: Maybe we’ll be a little less blind.
Lucia: 哦厨房还有个灯
Lucia: Oh, there's another light in the kitchen.
Jake: 对在这边少瞎一点
Jake: Yeah, let's turn it on so we’ll be less blind.
Lucia: great
Lucia: Great.
Tasha: 这都是调味料了
Tasha: These are all seasonings.
Alice: 调味料放
Alice: Put the seasonings...
Tasha: 柠檬和这个
Tasha: Lemons and this...
Alice: 下面可以放
Alice: You can put them below.
Lucia: 这个要不要拆一下
Lucia: Should we unpack this?
Lucia: 然后放这个冰箱
Lucia: And then put it in the fridge?
Tasha:  这个蔬菜
Tasha: This vegetable
Lucia: 蔬菜也放冰箱吗
Lucia: Should we put the vegetables in the fridge?
Lucia: 今天晚上又不吃
Lucia: We're not eating them tonight anyway.
Lucia: 还有这个
Lucia: And this one too.
Tasha: 他真是一个煞风景的东西
Tasha: It's really such a buzzkill.
Jake:谁
Jake: Who?
Tasha: 它
Tasha: It.
Jake:哦 这个
Jake: Oh, this one.
Alice: 放常温也可以啊
Alice: You can keep it at room temperature too.
Tasha: 不放冰箱
Tasha: Don't put it in the fridge.
Jake: 对啊放外边当武器挂门上
Jake: Yeah, hang it outside as a weapon.
Tasha: 这个是不是也是常温就可以
Tasha: This one can stay at room temperature too, right?
Jake:对啊对啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 这个我们拿的时候是常温的
Lucia: We got it at room temperature.
Jake:对啊放外边
Jake: Yeah, put it outside.
Alice:哦他是那个密封的搁这
Alice: Oh, it's sealed, put it there.
Jake:放外边放哪呢
Jake: Where to put it outside?
Katrina:  扔个垃圾
Katrina: Throw it away.
Lucia: 哎这不是垃圾桶吗
Lucia: Hey, isn't this the trash can?
Jake: 是垃圾桶
Jake: It is the trash can.
Jake: 但是 哎
Jake: But, hey.
Lucia: 他他他
Lucia: He, he, he.
Alice:那个内胆
Alice: The inner bucket.
Jake:哦哦哦哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Alice:用来醒花了
Alice: Used to wake up flowers.
Jake: 就这个已经被改装了
Jake: This has been modified.
Tasha: 改良了
Tasha: Improved.
Jake:给你看
Jake: Let me show you.
Jake: 改良成那个样子
Jake: Improved like this.
Jake: 哎改良完了
Jake: Hey, it's done.
Katrina: 我把饮料都放二楼了
Katrina: I put the drinks upstairs.
Lucia: 是这样的吗
Lucia: Is it like this?
Jake: 改完了是吧
Jake: It's done, right?
Alice: 用过了
Alice: Used it.
Jake:哦他们原来
Jake: Oh, they originally.
Jake: 他们原来把这个当作
Jake: They originally used this as.
Jake: 这个装花的容器啊
Jake: This container for flowers.
Lucia: 哦 ok
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Katrina:  我洗过了一点
Katrina: I washed it a bit.
Jake: 哎哎哎哎哎哎哎  呃OK
Jake: Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, uh, OK.
Jake: 现在是有了
Jake: Now we have it.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 这这个魔芋丝和这些
Lucia: This konjac strips and these...
Lucia: 这些是不是也是放冰箱的
Lucia: Should these also be put in the fridge?
Alice: 是的是的
Alice: Yes, yes.
Tasha: 这个葱姜蒜组合放外面就行了
Tasha: This green onion, ginger, and garlic combo can be left outside.
Lucia: 对葱姜蒜可以放外面
Lucia: Right, green onion, ginger, and garlic can be left outside.
Lucia: 里面嗯
Lucia: Inside, um...
Lucia: 土豆呢还有这个糕点吗那是
Lucia: What about potatoes and this pastry, are they...
Lucia: 两个葱姜蒜组合
Lucia: Two green onion, ginger, and garlic combos.
Tasha: 怕一个不够
Tasha: Afraid one isn't enough.
Lucia: 啊还有海盐
Lucia: Ah, and sea salt.
Lucia: 摇摇奶盖嗯
Lucia: Shake the milk cover, um...
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Lucia: 红薯应该是常温就可以吧
Lucia: Sweet potatoes should be fine at room temperature, right?
Lucia: 这个菜要不要放冰箱
Lucia: Does this vegetable need to go in the fridge?
Alice:这边
Alice: Over here.
Lucia: 这个今天晚上要用吗
Lucia: Are we using this tonight?
Alice: 不用
Alice: No.
露丝：那就放冰箱
Lucia: Then put it in the fridge.
Alice:可
Alice: Sure.
Alice:煞风景的来了
Alice: The mood killer is here.
Tasha: 这可乐不适合放在这里了已经
Tasha: This cola doesn't fit here anymore.
Lucia: 这个我觉得这个袋子里剩下的东西
Lucia: I think the stuff left in this bag...
Lucia: 应该都是放常温就行
Lucia: Should all be fine at room temperature.
Lucia: 大家可以检查一下
Lucia: Everyone can check.
Tasha: 午餐肉放进去吧
Tasha: Put the luncheon meat in the fridge.
Lucia: ok了
Lucia: Okay, done.
Jake: 哎我把这个倒掉
Jake: Hey, I'll pour this out.
Jake: 呃弄一个小垃圾袋吧
Jake: Uh, get a small trash bag.
Alice: 我要换个鞋
Alice: I need to change my shoes.
Tasha: 那就拿这个不就行了吗
Tasha: Why not just use this?
Jake: 这个太大了
Jake: This one's too big.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Alright.
Tasha: 这是这些也是火锅的
Tasha: These are for hot pot too.
Lucia: 刚那个火锅底料在哪放着呢
Lucia: Where did we put the hot pot base just now?
Tasha: 这呢这这都是调味料
Tasha: Here, these are all seasonings.
Alice:哪个是
Alice: Which one is it?
Tasha: 这个袋子里的
Tasha: It's in this bag.
Lucia: 那就把这个
Lucia: Then let's put this...
Alice:火锅底料在这呢
Alice: The hot pot base is here.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 那要不把那个火锅底料也放到这里面
Lucia: How about we put the hot pot base in here too?
Lucia: 然后这个
Lucia: And then this.
Lucia: 这个红薯跟这些东西放一起
Lucia: Put the sweet potatoes and these things together.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Lucia: 为什么我买了两袋红薯
Lucia: Why did I buy two bags of sweet potatoes?
Tasha: 一不一样的
Tasha: They're different.
Alice: 不样的品种
Alice: Different varieties.
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, OK.
Tasha: 这个鸡蛋放哪里呢
Tasha: Where do I put these eggs?
Tasha: 哎呦这个厨房好小呀
Tasha: Oh, this kitchen is so small.
Alice: 这这这置物架
Alice: This, this, this shelf.
Alice: 置物架
Alice: The shelf.
Tasha: 可是感觉哎
Tasha: But it feels like, hey...
Tasha: 放这不太好拿
Tasha: It's not easy to reach there.
Alice: 没事用的时候再拿出来
Alice: It's okay, just take it out when we need it.
Lucia: 这个要不就放这个里面
Lucia: How about we put this in here?
Lucia: 跟这些放一起
Lucia: Together with these.
Alice:就调味料那些
Alice: With the seasonings.
Lucia: 然后装就暂时放这袋子里
Lucia: And temporarily put it in this bag.
Lucia: 那个咖啡放这里面
Lucia: The coffee goes in here.
Alice: 也放里面吧
Alice: Put it in there too.
Alice: 这个没地安置
Alice: There's no place for this.
Alice: 他也放那吧
Alice: Just put it there too.
Alice: 感觉他在哪里都不好看
Alice: It doesn't look good anywhere.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake: 就放这了
Jake: Just put it here.
Jake: 啊这两个
Jake: Ah, these two.
Tasha: 怎么了
Tasha: What's up?
Jake: 还要吗
Jake: Do you still need them?
Tasha: 额
Tasha: Uh.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This.
Jake: 就放这吧
Jake: Just put it here.
Tasha: 就放这
Tasha: Just put it here.
Lucia: 要一下 要一下也行
Lucia: If you need it, just take it.
Lucia: 这个会坏的这么快吗
Lucia: Will this spoil so quickly?
Alice: 昨天到现在都快24小时
Alice: It's been almost 24 hours since yesterday.
Alice:赶紧给它喝了不得了
Alice: Hurry up and drink it.
Tasha: 因为
Tasha: Because...
Lucia: 咱今天晚上把它喝了要不
Lucia: How about we drink it tonight?
Tasha: 嗯，不要再放了
Tasha: Hmm, don't put it away again.
Jake: 这玻璃隔音确实一般
Jake: This glass isn't very soundproof.
Jake: 听的还挺呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: I can hear it pretty clearly, haha.
Alice:清楚的
Alice: It's clear.
Jake: 丢掉了
Jake: Threw it away.
Katrina:  你那个蛋挞皮跟芋泥是怎么弄的芋圆
Katrina: How did you make that tart crust and taro balls?
Alice:荔浦芋头就行
Alice: Just use Lipu taro.
Katrina:  买了吗
Katrina: Did you buy it?
Alice:没有没有了
Alice: No, I didn't.
Katrina:  我的外送还是快递的
Katrina: Is mine delivery or courier?
Tasha: 我挑好了
Tasha: I picked it out.
Tasha: 呃快递的
Tasha: Uh, it's courier.
Katrina: 就是你买的是吧
Katrina: So you bought it, right?
Katrina:  蛋挞皮跟那个芋头
Katrina: The tart crust and that taro.
Tasha: 挑好了还没下单呢
Tasha: Picked it out but haven't ordered yet.
Katrina:  哦我给你寄一下
Katrina: Oh, I'll send it to you.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 还有展架
Tasha: There's also a display stand.
Jake: 帮我干一下
Jake: Help me with this.
Alice: 干一下
Alice: Help with this.
Jake:就帮我这个
Jake: Just help me with this.
Tasha: 扒拉一下
Tasha: Give it a push.
Jake:哎
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 这两个就留在这
Jake: Leave these two here.
Alice:我想换个鞋
Alice: I want to change shoes.
Jake: 看看还有什么垃圾我一起扔出去
Jake: See if there's any other trash, I'll throw it out together.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Okay.
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one.
Lucia: 这个是什么
Lucia: What's this?
Jake: 这个得是垃圾对
Jake: This must be trash, right?
Tasha: 呦 这个时候应该派出我们的
Tasha: Oh, at this time, we should send out our...
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:哦吼吼吼吼吼
Jake: Oh, ho ho ho ho ho.
Lucia: 吼有道理
Lucia: Makes sense.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Lucia: 先看一下一会把就是该扔的都扔了
Lucia: First, see what needs to be thrown away.
Lucia: 然后再擦
Lucia: Then clean up.
Katrina:  还好没有买时钟
Katrina: Good thing we didn't buy the clock.
Lucia: 还有没有啥要扔的
Lucia: Is there anything else to throw away?
Tasha: 没有买什么
Tasha: Didn't buy anything.
Katrina: 时钟
Katrina: Clock.
Alice: 有那个厨房
Alice: There's that kitchen...
Alice:湿巾
Alice: Wet wipes.
Katrina:  快递
Katrina: Delivery.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice:就是一个普通的钟就行了
Alice: Just a regular clock will do.
Katrina: 还有还有就是
Katrina: And also...
Lucia: 你透气啊
Lucia: Are you out of breath?
Katrina:  要挂的吗
Katrina: Do you want it to hang?
Katrina:  还是白的
Katrina: Or white?
Jake: 呃我来买这个就好
Jake: Uh, I'll just buy it myself.
Tasha: 为什么要买时钟
Tasha: Why do we need a clock?
Katrina:  我不知道他这些啊
Katrina: I don't know about these things.
Jake: 因为要计时
Jake: Because we need to keep time.
Jake: 就就 3个小时就要听
Jake: Every 3 hours, we need to listen.
Tasha: 那个呃
Tasha: That, uh...
Tasha: 盒子
Tasha: Box.
Alice: 啥盒子
Alice: What box?
Tasha: 就是甜品不同的盒子
Tasha: Just different boxes for desserts.
Tasha: 对甜品盒
Tasha: Yes, dessert boxes.
Tasha: 行就这么多应该就这行
Tasha: Okay, that's it, should be enough.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:妙啊
Jake: Perfect.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah...
Lucia: 其他的应该收拾的差不多
Lucia: Everything else should be almost done.
Jake:扔完了是吧
Jake: All thrown out, right?
Jake: 那我出去扔掉
Jake: Then I'll go throw it out.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 这俩袋子
Lucia: These two bags.
Lucia: 可以留着就这两天在倒垃圾用
Lucia: We can keep them for trash in the next two days.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 那个是什么
Jake: What's that?
Lucia: 薇传
Lucia: Plastic wrap.
Tasha: 保鲜膜
Tasha: Cling film.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Lucia: 你说这个吗
Lucia: You mean this one?
Lucia: 呃这个
Lucia: Uh, this one.
Alice: 那个鲜花的
Alice: The one with fresh flowers.
Tasha: 营养剂
Tasha: Nutrient solution.
Lucia: 这是花的营养液
Lucia: This is flower nutrient solution.
Alice:可以把它扔了
Alice: You can throw it away.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice: 不用也行对
Alice: You don't need to use it.
Katrina:  倒进去要不要
Katrina: Should we pour it in?
Jake: 啊不用了
Jake: Ah, no need.
Lucia: 这个需要用吗
Lucia: Do we need to use this?
Alice:就 可以不用
Alice: No, we don't need to.
Tasha: 哦用的话花会活的更久
Tasha: Oh, if we use it, the flowers will live longer.
Katrina:  那往里面倒一点我
Katrina: Then let's pour a little in.
Katrina:  我来倒哈哈
Katrina: I'll pour it, haha.
Jake: 那就不用了
Jake: Then there's no need.
Lucia: 那就随便了
Lucia: Then it's whatever.
Lucia: 我来倒太懂了
Lucia: I'll pour it, I know this.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Jake: 打了起来
Jake: They started fighting.
Lucia: 哈哈打了起来
Lucia: Haha, they started fighting.
Jake:扎马炮喜欢呵呵
Jake: Zama likes it, haha.
Katrina:  打起来打起来
Katrina: Fight, fight.
Jake: 喜欢打起来
Jake: He likes fighting.
Jake: 喜欢
Jake: Likes it.
Jake: 好数据
Jake: Good data.
Katrina: 什么时候打起来他就高兴了
Katrina: Whenever there's a fight, he's happy.
Katrina:  有素材了
Katrina: Got some content.
Lucia: 增加一些动态的打架效果是吧
Lucia: Add some dynamic fighting effects, right?
Katrina:  他那个点外卖了吗
Katrina: Did he order takeout?
Lucia: 哎这是哦
Lucia: Ah, that's it.
Lucia: 我还
Lucia: I still...
Katrina: 就是这个
Katrina: It's this one.
Lucia: 这他这他今天一天开成这样的吗
Lucia: Did he keep it like this the whole day?
Katrina:  这个东西他会长成这个
Katrina: This thing will grow like this.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Katrina: 因为他
Katrina: Because it...
Lucia: 因为我记得拿出来的时候他还是
Lucia: Because I remember when it was taken out, it was still...
Lucia: 都还是花苞
Lucia: It was still a bud.
Katrina:  对对对他芍药是送的是花球
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, the peony was sent as a flower ball.
Alice: 嗯然后那个量就是他不能不能太浓
Alice: Hmm, and the amount shouldn't be too concentrated.
Katrina:  嗯这个芍药容易分到6个里面
Katrina: Yeah, this peony easily splits into six pieces.
Lucia: 太浓了是容易给他扎  虫吗
Lucia: If it's too concentrated, does it easily attract insects?
Alice:烧死
Alice: Burn it.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 我之前养一个水蚤
Lucia: I used to raise a water flea.
Lucia: 是就是如果加多了会容易长虫
Lucia: If you overfeed it, it can easily breed bugs.
Lucia: 就是营养过剩然后就
Lucia: It's like overnutrition, then...
Katrina:  稍等一下
Katrina: Hold on a sec.
Alice: 哎呦
Alice: Ouch.
Katrina:  他们点外卖了吗
Katrina: Did they order takeout?
Lucia: 好像还没有
Lucia: Seems like they haven't yet.
Alice: 还没点
Alice: Not yet.
Alice:我们今天这是录的第几段啊
Alice: How many segments have we recorded today?
Alice: 第二段吧
Alice: This should be the second one.
Lucia: 对应该还
Lucia: Yeah, I think so.
Alice: 是不是还有俩还有一段
Alice: Do we have two more or just one?
Lucia: 可能还有一个两个小时
Lucia: Probably one or two hours left.
Katrina:  但是晚上好像没说啥活动哎
Katrina: But there's no plan for tonight, right?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Alice: 明天啥活动
Alice: What's the plan for tomorrow?
Alice: 那怎么有个咖啡啊
Alice: How come there's a coffee here?
Lucia: 刚买的吧
Lucia: Maybe someone just bought it.
Alice: 给他归置到哪
Alice: Where should we put it?
Alice: 火锅底料那
Alice: With the hotpot base?
Alice: 那不算给他给他放着吧
Alice: Never mind, just leave it there.
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 因为
Lucia: Because...
Lucia: 因为有一个速溶咖啡在火锅底料里
Lucia: There's an instant coffee in the hotpot base.
Alice: 这个好看的放冰箱里
Alice: Put the nice one in the fridge.
Alice: 虽然它不用放冰箱
Alice: Even though it doesn't need refrigeration.
Alice: 但我就想把它放冰箱
Alice: But I just want to put it in the fridge.
Alice:哎
Alice: Oh.
Katrina:  嗯嗯
Katrina: Hmm, hmm.
Lucia: 这里面还放了几只
Lucia: There are a few more in here.
Katrina:  哎 12341234是6个
Katrina: Hey, 1, 2, 3, 4, 1, 2, 3, 4, it's 6.
Katrina:  6个用一包应该没事吧
Katrina: 6 should be fine with one packet, right?
Alice: 这上面应该有
Alice: It should say on it.
Alice: 那个浓度多少升
Alice: How many liters for the concentration?
Alice: 配比的那个
Alice: The mix ratio.
Katrina:  0点三liters什么意思
Katrina: What does 0.3 liters mean?
Katrina:  呃Rage 0.3升
Katrina: Uh, range 0.3 liters.
Jake:l升
Jake: 1 liter.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh
Lucia: 就是300毫升
Lucia: It's 300 milliliters.
Jake:哎这个
Jake: Hey, this...
Lucia: 我觉得咱这个应该稀释
Lucia: I think we should dilute this.
Katrina:  每一包用0.3升的水
Katrina: Each pack uses 0.3 liters of water.
Katrina:  这都有3升了
Katrina: That's already 3 liters.
Lucia: 那那肯定够了
Lucia: Then that should be enough.
Alice: 0.3升对这么浓的吗
Alice: 0.3 liters for something this strong?
Jake:300毫升
Jake: 300 milliliters.
Alice: 他就给了一包哎
Alice: He only gave one pack.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Jake: 试一试新买的湿巾纸
Jake: Let's try the new wet wipes we bought.
Katrina:  每包0.3升水是不是
Katrina: Each pack uses 0.3 liters of water, right?
Jake: 嗯这300毫80毫升0.38
Jake: Hmm, this is 300 milliliters plus 80 milliliters... 0.38.
Alice: 这么多花
Alice: So many flowers.
Alice: 他才给了一包既然不是那种
Alice: He only gave one pack, not that kind.
Katrina:  这也不知道谁的水
Katrina: Don't know whose water this is.
Katrina:  用来浇花吧
Katrina: Let's use it to water the plants.
Alice: 哎我刚打开的哦
Alice: Hey, I just opened it.
Katrina:  哈哈哈我以为是我早上的呢
Katrina: Hahaha, I thought it was mine from this morning.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hehehe, hahaha.
Jake: 其实是知道的呵呵
Jake: Actually, I knew, hehe.
Katrina:  想制造冲突哈哈哈
Katrina: Trying to create some conflict, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 背景音乐来个音效
Jake: Background music, let's add a sound effect.
Lucia: 嘿Siri
Lucia: Hey Siri.
Jake:呵呵呵哈哈哈
Jake: Hehehe, hahaha.
Lucia: 啊让Siri放首歌
Lucia: Ah, let's have Siri play a song.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Alice: 啊不用洗洁精吗
Alice: Ah, don't we need dish soap?
Jake: 用用用只是试一下这个
Jake: Yes, yes, we do. Just trying this out.
Lucia: 试一下这个厨房纸
Lucia: Let's try this kitchen paper.
Jake: 对对给他点面子
Jake: Yeah, yeah, give it some face.
Jake: 买都买了
Jake: We bought it already.
Jake: 用他一下
Jake: Let's use it.
Alice: 买都买了
Alice: We bought it already.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Lucia: 等到咱们吃火锅的时候他应该很有用
Lucia: When we have hotpot, it should be useful.
Jake: 哦对
Jake: Oh, right.
Jake: 外卖咱还没点了
Jake: We haven't ordered takeout yet.
Katrina:  呃点吧现在有点饿
Katrina: Uh, can we order something? I'm a bit hungry.
Jake: 咱午饭没多久但是可以饿
Jake: We just had lunch not long ago, but I guess it's possible to be hungry.
Katrina:  我感觉我属于那种饱的快
Katrina: I feel like I get full quickly.
Katrina:  饿的也快那种
Katrina: And get hungry quickly too.
Katrina:  少吃多餐
Katrina: Small meals, multiple times.
Lucia: 这是什么呀
Lucia: What is this?
Jake:就是
Jake: It's...
Alice: 沙球
Alice: Sand ball.
Lucia: 是这样玩的吗
Lucia: Is this how you play it?
Jake: 呃这个是
Jake: Uh, this is...
Alice:配乐的
Alice: For the music.
Katrina:  这样这样这样这样
Katrina: Like this, like this, like this.
Jake: 这是修硕的
Jake: This is Shure's.
Jake: 小礼品
Jake: Little gift.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake: 这个好像还没有互相送
Jake: It seems we haven't exchanged gifts yet.
Katrina:  没有交换礼物这个环节
Katrina: There's no gift exchange session.
Jake: 有我忘了
Jake: Oh, I forgot.
Katrina: 啊对啊对
Katrina: Yeah, right.
Jake:第一天我忘了
Jake: I forgot on the first day.
Katrina:  我说还没有到
Katrina: I was saying it hasn't happened yet.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alice: 我以为要放在后边呢
Alice: I thought it was supposed to be later.
Jake: 嗯对这个每天都整点小游戏嘛
Jake: Yeah, we just do some small games every day.
Alice: 把那个叶子给它捞出来
Alice: Get that leaf out.
Alice: 要不然它会烂
Alice: Otherwise, it will rot.
Katrina:  哦我感觉我不太懂这边
Katrina: Oh, I feel like I don't really get this part.
Jake: 就是各位破冰破的太快了
Jake: It's like everyone broke the ice too quickly.
Jake: 一下就破了
Jake: It happened instantly.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha.
Lucia: 一下就破了
Lucia: It happened instantly.
Jake: 哈哈哈感觉不用什么礼物
Jake: Haha, feels like we don't need gifts.
Lucia: 迅速的熟识了起来
Lucia: We got to know each other quickly.
Jake: 对感觉不用什么礼物
Jake: Yeah, feels like we don't need gifts.
Jake:呵
Jake: Heh.
Lucia: 芍药真的好好看哦
Lucia: These peonies are really beautiful.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Alice:嗯
Katrina:  你看我的压花
Katrina: Look at my pressed flowers.
Lucia: 哇这咖啡这么好
Lucia: Wow, this coffee is so good.
Jake: 你们谁先选
Jake: Who wants to choose first?
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:就是你了
Jake: It's you.
Jake: 选一家
Jake: Pick one.
Tasha: 干嘛
Tasha: Why?
Lucia: 选个吃的吧
Lucia: Pick something to eat.
Tasha: 就这几家选吗
Tasha: Just from these few options?
Jake: 应该不止几家
Jake: There should be more than a few.
Alice: 这个是不是也快到时间了
Alice: Is this one almost out of time too?
Alice: 慢
Alice: Slow.
Jake: 呃你可以看一下这个还有多少story
Jake: Uh, you can check how much story is left.
Jake: 120G是三个小时啊
Jake: 120G lasts for three hours.
Jake: 110G三个小时
Jake: 110G for three hours.
Alice: 哦还有40多G
Alice: Oh, there's over 40G left.
Tasha: 那我吃这个吧
Tasha: Then I'll eat this.
Jake:ok
Jake: Okay.
Alice:啥呀
Alice: What?
Tasha: 私房菜
Tasha: Homemade food.
Alice:死亡菜
Alice: Death food?
Tasha: 私房菜
Tasha: Homemade food.
Alice: 哦私房菜
Alice: Oh, homemade food.
Jake: 酸菜炖
Jake: Pickled cabbage stew.
Tasha: 啊我没有说要吃这个菜啊
Tasha: Oh, I didn't say I wanted that dish.
Jake: 我知道我知道OK
Jake: I know, I know, okay.
Jake: 红烧土豆   红烧土豆
Jake: Braised potatoes, braised potatoes.
Jake: 哈哈他叫土豆侠子你知道吗
Jake: Haha, he's called Potato Hero, you know?
Alice: 土豆侠子
Alice: Potato Hero.
Lucia: 所以会吃土豆有关系吗还是
Lucia: So does that mean he eats a lot of potatoes or...
Jake: 上来给我看一堆土豆
Jake: He showed me a bunch of potatoes.
Alice: 他喜欢土豆
Alice: He likes potatoes.
Jake: 喜欢吃土豆
Jake: Loves eating potatoes.
Tasha: 是的只要花298就可以加入我的土门
Tasha: Yes, for just 298 you can join my potato club.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 那是因为
Lucia: That's because...
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 但是因为这个所以叫土豆侠子吗
Lucia: But is that why he's called Potato Hero?
Jake:天天都可以吃土豆
Jake: He can eat potatoes every day.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia: 就是是因为
Lucia: So is it because
Lucia: 你是因为喜欢吃土豆
Lucia: You like eating potatoes
Lucia: 所以叫土豆侠子的吗
Lucia: That you're called Potato Knight?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 怎么觉得听起来有点像
Lucia: Why does it sound like
Lucia: 一个编出来的理由
Lucia: You made up that reason?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 门店热销土豆红烧肉盖饭就这个吧
Jake: The store's best-seller is the potato and braised pork rice bowl, right?
Tasha: 啊每个人吃自己的饭是吗
Tasha: Ah, so everyone eats their own meal?
Tasha: 哦也可以
Tasha: Oh, that works too.
Jake: 哦你说点这种大菜是吧
Jake: Oh, you mean ordering larger dishes, right?
Tasha: 哦我以为是点大菜
Tasha: Oh, I thought we were ordering larger dishes.
Jake: 哦那也行啊点大菜
Jake: Oh, that works too, let's order larger dishes.
Jake: 那每人点一个吧
Jake: Then each person can order one.
Tasha: 每人点一个
Tasha: Each person orders one.
Tasha: 嗯四个女生
Tasha: Hmm, four girls.
Tasha: 我感觉吃两到三个菜就差不多了
Tasha: I think two to three dishes should be enough.
Jake: 行
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 对差不多
Lucia: Yeah, that should be enough.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake: 那你先点一个
Jake: Then you order first.
Jake: 你先点个土豆吧
Jake: You go ahead and order a potato dish.
Tasha: 不
Tasha: No.
Jake:啊你找一个土豆店不点土豆
Jake: Ah, you come to a potato place and don't order potatoes?
Lucia: 点一个里面带土豆的菜
Lucia: Order a dish that has potatoes in it.
Katrina:  点那种什么肉蟹煲
Katrina: Order something like a meat and crab pot.
Katrina:  什么什么煲里面很多土豆
Katrina: Those kinds of pots have lots of potatoes.
Katrina:  就是他根本就没有那么多肉
Katrina: It doesn't really have that much meat.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 哇感觉好好吃
Tasha: Wow, sounds delicious.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Alice: 哪个
Alice: Which one?
Jake:想象出来的肉蟹煲
Jake: The meat and crab pot we imagined.
Jake: 土豆包
Jake: Potato pot.
Alice:吓我一跳
Alice: You scared me.
Tasha: 记得备注一下不要香菜
Tasha: Remember to note no cilantro.
Alice:你说啥呀
Alice: What did you say?
Tasha: 不要啥菜啊
Tasha: No cilantro, right?
Alice: 你点的啥
Alice: What did you order?
Alice: 我点了个水煮肉
Alice: I ordered boiled meat.
Alice: 麻辣水煮肉猪肉
Alice: Spicy boiled pork.
Tasha: 你你不吃猪肉吗
Tasha: Don't you not eat pork?
Alice: 你会你认识这个字吗
Alice: Do you recognize this character?
Tasha: 干靠大牙呵呵
Tasha: Um... just guessing, haha.
Tasha: 这不是鹅吗
Tasha: Isn't this goose?
Katrina:  哇康乃馨花瓣居然要分开吗
Katrina: Wow, do we need to separate the carnation petals?
Lucia: 小鸡炖蘑菇
Lucia: Chicken stew with mushrooms.
Tasha: 这个好用吗
Tasha: Is this any good?
Alice:那个在哪啊
Alice: Where is it?
Tasha: 这个厨房湿巾
Tasha: This kitchen wipe.
Lucia: 没有没有我不是说要点这个
Lucia: No, no, I didn't mean to order this.
Lucia: 我就是刚
Lucia: I was just...
Tasha: 我说这个好用吗
Tasha: I mean, is this good?
Lucia: 好像还不错的样子
Lucia: It seems pretty good.
Alice:还可以
Alice: It's okay.
Tasha: 哇感觉它好便宜啊
Tasha: Wow, it seems really cheap.
Alice:从上面吗
Lucia: 哎它多少钱一包啊
Lucia: Hey, how much is it per pack?
Tasha: 九块九
Tasha: Nine yuan and ninety cents.
Katrina:  九块九这
Katrina: Nine yuan and ninety cents, this...
Lucia: 哎还挺大包哎
Lucia: Hey, it's quite a big pack.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 我感觉一片就可以把所有的碗都抹了
Tasha: I feel like one sheet can wipe all the bowls.
Lucia: 哈哈哈对对对
Lucia: Haha, yes, exactly.
Lucia: 正确用法
Lucia: Proper usage.
Katrina:  想想还有什么
Katrina: Think about what else.
Lucia: 来看看菜吗姐妹
Lucia: Let's check out the dishes, sisters.
Katrina: 好的
Katrina: Okay.
Katrina:  哦点家常菜是吧
Katrina: Oh, we're ordering home-style dishes, right?
Alice: 点大菜好像说的是无所谓吧
Alice: Ordering big dishes seems to be no big deal.
Katrina:  现在点了什么
Katrina: What did we order now?
Alice: 嗯麻辣水煮肉
Alice: Uh, spicy boiled pork.
Katrina:  我想吃孜然牛肉
Katrina: I want to eat cumin beef.
Tasha: 冰箱居然没有关
Tasha: The fridge isn't closed.
Alice:关了呀
Alice: It is closed.
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No, it isn't.
Alice:没关严是吧
Alice: Not tightly, huh?
Katrina:  啊啊看看你们这装满
Katrina: Ah, look, it's full.
Katrina:  这上面还有好大的位置哦
Katrina: There's still a lot of space here.
Katrina:  牛奶在这里
Katrina: The milk is here.
Katrina:  上面全是酒哦
Katrina: The top is all alcohol.
Alice:你想吃的吗
Katrina:  啊养乐多在这
Katrina: Ah, Yakult is here.
Alice:木须肉
Alice: Moo Shu Pork.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 别哈哈哈
Lucia: Stop laughing.
Alice: 唤起你的回忆了吗
Alice: Did it bring back memories?
Tasha: 你看我的眼睛
Tasha: Look at my eyes.
Tasha: 这里好好热呀
Tasha: It's really hot here.
Katrina:  嗯我也是
Katrina: Yeah, me too.
Katrina:  他工作久了
Katrina: He's been working for a long time.
Alice: 是这是这吗
Alice: Is it this one?
Lucia: 哦眼镜对对对
Lucia: Oh, glasses, yes, yes.
Alice:眼有点烫
Alice: Eyes feel a bit hot.
Lucia: 这个这个
Lucia: This one, this one.
Lucia: 电池好像比较容易烫的样子
Lucia: Batteries seem to get hot easily.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina:  今天我那一小辫
Katrina: Today, my little braid...
Alice:这是你最爱的毛旺呵呵呵呵呵
Alice: This is your favorite Mao Wang, hehehe.
Lucia: 哈哈哈点一个不要备注
Lucia: Hahaha, order one without any notes.
Lucia: 不要血块
Lucia: No blood clots.
Lucia: 哈哈给店家干蒙了
Lucia: Hahaha, the shop owner was confused.
Katrina:  哇好温馨
Katrina: Wow, so cozy.
Lucia: 我都可以你可以看看 你比较想吃什么
Lucia: I'm fine with anything. You can look around and see what you want to eat.
Tasha: 都是用钱堆出来的
Tasha: All of this was built with money.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia: 刚刚那个姐妹点的孜然牛肉就是
Lucia: The cumin beef the girl just ordered...
Lucia: 已经基本上是我想要点的菜了
Lucia: It's basically the dish I wanted to order.
Lucia: 很重合
Lucia: It's very similar.
Lucia: 干锅娃娃菜
Lucia: Dry pot baby cabbage.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:你想要吗
Alice: Do you want it?
Tasha: 干锅什么
Tasha: Dry pot what?
Alice:娃娃菜
Alice: Baby cabbage.
Alice: 要吗
Alice: Do you want it?
Lucia: 没有没有
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia: 我是说你好像喜欢吃娃娃菜的样子
Lucia: I was saying you seem to like baby cabbage.
Alice: 我我一般还行
Alice: Me, I'm okay with it.
Lucia: 啊OK 因为你之前说你做那个
Lucia: Ah okay, because you said you made that...
Tasha: 上汤娃娃菜
Tasha: Stewed baby cabbage in broth.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Jake: 哎对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake: 你们晚上是propose的什么活动来着
Jake: What activity did you propose for tonight?
Tasha: propose了
Tasha: We proposed...
Jake: 你们是逛超市的时候
Jake: When you were shopping at the supermarket...
Alice:这边点一个吧
Alice: Let's order here.
Jake: propose的两个什么
Jake: You proposed two things, right?
Jake: 要做菜做甜品
Jake: Cooking and making desserts.
Jake: 做半个小时甜点
Jake: Making dessert for half an hour.
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: Sure.
Jake:OK
Jake: Okay.
Alice: 你为啥不点土豆啊
Alice: Why don't you order potatoes?
Alice: 我给你点上吧
Alice: Let me order them for you.
Alice: 哈哈排骨土豆炖豆角
Alice: Haha, pork ribs with potatoes and beans.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice: 还有啥土豆啊
Alice: What else with potatoes?
Alice: 给你找都
Alice: I'll find it for you.
Tasha: 都可以都可以
Tasha: Anything is fine.
Alice: 排骨土豆
Alice: Pork ribs with potatoes.
Tasha: 要不要吃回锅肉
Tasha: How about twice-cooked pork?
Alice: 那你不要你的土豆了
Alice: Then you don't want your potatoes?
Tasha: 可以不要
Tasha: I can skip them.
Tasha: 哈哈回锅肉
Tasha: Haha, twice-cooked pork.
Tasha: 锅包肉锅包肉
Tasha: Sweet and sour pork.
Tasha: 番茄牛腩
Tasha: Tomato beef brisket.
Jake: 白板担当
Jake: Whiteboard duty.
Tasha: 嗯都可以
Tasha: Hmm, anything is fine.
Alice: 这个或者
Alice: This one or...
Jake:留的
Jake: Stay.
Alice: 哎你刚说哪个
Alice: Hey, which one did you just say?
Tasha: 锅包肉回锅肉
Tasha: Sweet and sour pork, twice-cooked pork.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:要两种肉
Jake: Want two kinds of meat.
Alice:麻辣的孜然的
Alice: Spicy cumin.
Alice: 这是酸辣的
Alice: This is hot and sour.
Alice: 你更想吃哪个
Alice: Which one do you want to eat more?
Alice:锅包肉还是
Alice: Sweet and sour pork or...
Katrina:  是我们四个
Katrina: It's the four of us.
Katrina:  还带他一起吗
Katrina: Are we taking him with us?
Katrina:  一起的是吧
Katrina: Together, right?
Lucia: 对我们一起四个菜
Lucia: Yes, the four of us together.
Katrina:  三荤一素
Katrina: Three meat dishes and one vegetable.
Tasha: 三
Tasha: Three.
Tasha: 哦有素菜吗
Tasha: Oh, is there a vegetable dish?
Tasha: 我们没有点过素菜
Tasha: We haven't ordered any vegetable dishes.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Alice: 你更想吃哪个你点两个吧我也挑不上
Alice: Which one do you want to eat more? You pick two, I can't decide.
Lucia:或者或者或者番茄牛腩
Lucia: Or, or, or tomato beef stew.
Lucia: 里面有番茄
Lucia: It has tomatoes in it.
Lucia: 哈哈是吧
Lucia: Haha, right?
Lucia: 姑且算是半个素菜
Lucia: Let's consider it half a vegetable dish.
Tasha: 那那素菜
Tasha: Then, for the vegetable dish,
Tasha: 素菜里面要一个手撕包菜
Tasha: Let's have hand-torn cabbage.
Tasha: 或者要一个酸辣土豆丝
Tasha: Or spicy and sour shredded potatoes.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice: 土豆在这等着呢啊
Alice: The potatoes are waiting here.
Tasha: 啊就这个吧
Tasha: Ah, let's go with this one.
Alice: 点吧
Alice: Order it.
Tasha: 然后刚刚那个菜
Tasha: And then the dish just now.
Alice:稍薇有个荤菜在这
Alice: There's a meat dish here, Tasha.
Alice:这
Alice: Here.
Alice: 番茄牛腩
Alice: Tomato beef stew.
Alice: 还是啥可以
Alice: Or whatever, it's fine.
Tasha: 回锅肉会不会便宜点
Tasha: Would twice-cooked pork be cheaper?
Alice: 这都差不多
Alice: They're all about the same.
Tasha: 40 68 58都可以
Tasha: 40, 68, 58, they're all fine.
Alice: 哪有62 你说哪有62
Alice: Where's 62? What are you talking about?
Tasha:  68 42
Tasha: 68, 42.
Alice:要哪个
Alice: Which one to get?
Tasha: 看都有啥
Tasha: Let's see what they have.
Tasha: 还差个汤
Tasha: We're missing a soup.
Tasha: 现在就开始煮吧
Tasha: Should we start cooking now?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice:现在开始煮汤
Alice: Start cooking the soup now?
Alice: 今天晚上就喝吧
Alice: Let's drink it tonight.
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right?
Tasha: 是今天晚上开始做汤吗
Tasha: Are we starting to make the soup tonight?
Katrina:  反正吃家常菜吗
Katrina: Anyway, just eating homemade dishes.
Jake: 可以啊你说等的时候做汤吗
Jake: Sure, you mean making soup while waiting?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 他要送多久啊
Jake: How long will it take to deliver?
Jake: 40分钟
Jake: 40 minutes.
Alice:可能吧
Alice: Maybe.
Katrina:  送密封袋
Katrina: Delivering in a sealed bag.
Tasha: 现在是7点半
Tasha: It's 7:30 now.
Katrina:  那我试验一下
Katrina: Let me test it out.
Tasha: 那我现在开始在做甜品的话
Tasha: If I start making dessert now...
Tasha: 8点半还能开会哦
Tasha: We can still have a meeting at 8:30.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Katrina:  今天晚上开会吗
Katrina: Are we having a meeting tonight?
Alice: 点这个吧
Alice: Just choose this one.
Jake:她要开会
Jake: She wants to have a meeting.
Alice: 我不太想吃猪
Alice: I don't really want to eat pork.
Alice: 可以吗
Alice: Is that okay?
Tasha: 可以啊可以
Tasha: Yeah, sure.
Jake: 他自己要开会
Jake: He wants to have the meeting himself.
Katrina:  我可能有点事
Katrina: I might have something to do.
Jake:他学校
Jake: His school...
Alice:对
Alice: Right.
Alice: 那我们开始做吧
Alice: Let's get started then.
Alice: 你让他点
Alice: You let him choose.
Katrina:  摘两片芍药花瓣
Katrina: Pick two peony petals.
Tasha: 神圣的交接仪
Tasha: The sacred handover ceremony.
Alice: 来吧我们开始吧
Alice: Come on, let's start.
Tasha: 好我们开始吧
Tasha: Alright, let's begin.
Alice: 我们几个人做汤的话需要
Alice: If we're making soup, we need...
Tasha: 你需要一个配手
Tasha: You need a helper.
Tasha: 我需要一个配手
Tasha: I need a helper.
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Right?
Alice:哦我不需要哦
Alice: Oh, I don't need one.
Alice: 我可以自己给自己打下手
Alice: I can help myself.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Awesome.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Alright.
Katrina:  好 需要我帮忙吗
Katrina: Okay, do you need my help?
Alice: 我们需要做多少量呢
Alice: How much do we need to make?
Tasha: 嗯一人一碗的量就行
Tasha: Hmm, just a bowl for each person.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Alice:一人一碗是
Alice: Everyone gets a bowl
Alice: 哎我不知道大家的饭量
Alice: I don't know how much everyone eats
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm
Lucia: 汤嘛
Lucia: Soup?
Alice:对
Alice: Yes
Lucia: 汤就
Lucia: For the soup
Alice: 多一点应该也没事
Alice: A bit more should be fine
Lucia:这个多少应该
Lucia: How much should it be?
Alice: 好那我把我戒指取下来
Alice: Okay, I'll take off my ring
Alice: 不行都放不掉
Alice: Nope, it won't come off
Lucia: 需要我做什么呢
Lucia: Do you need me to do something?
Alice:算了带上吧
Alice: Forget it, I'll just wear it
Lucia: 哈哈哈等待指派中
Lucia: Hahaha, waiting for instructions
Tasha: 等一下
Tasha: Wait a second
Jake:我问一下谢明珠来不来
Jake: I'll ask if Xie Mingzhu is coming
Jake: 他有可能来
Jake: He might come
Jake: 来的话就多加一个人
Jake: If he comes, we'll add one more person
Alice:谁
Alice: Who?
Tasha: 哎米饭是不是没点
Tasha: Hey, did we order the rice?
Alice:谁来
Alice: Who's coming?
Jake:谢冰竹
Jake: Xie Bingzhu
Tasha: 米饭掉了吗
Tasha: Did the rice fall?
Jake: 就是那个
Jake: No, we didn't order it
Jake: 没有没点
Jake: No, we didn't
Tasha: 为什么不点米饭
Tasha: Why didn't you order rice?
Jake: 因为我还没下单呢
Jake: Because I haven't placed the order yet
Tasha: 哦那就行
Tasha: Oh, then that's fine
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehehe
Alice: 那我现在开始吧
Alice: Then I'll start now
Jake:害怕
Jake: Scared
Tasha: 好的你先开始
Tasha: Alright, you start first
Jake:害怕
Jake: Scared
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh no
Lucia: 我要不简单的
Lucia: Should I make something simple?
Lucia: 做饭的话我要不要换个洞
Lucia: If I'm cooking, should I change to another hole?
Alice:不应该放冷冻
Alice: Shouldn't it be in the freezer?
Lucia: 我能把它先摘下来一下吗
Lucia: Can I take it off for a moment?
Lucia: 我换个衣服
Lucia: I'm going to change my clothes
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 这样好做一点
Lucia: This way it's easier.
Lucia: 不用关吧
Lucia: No need to turn it off, right?
Jake:你就放在这里对对对嗯嗯
Jake: Just place it here, yes, yes, mm-hmm.
Lucia: 我在这里放一下吧
Lucia: I'll put it here for now.
Lucia: 然后一会再下去
Lucia: And then I'll come back down later.
Alice: 哎呀冻得梆梆硬
Alice: Oh, it's frozen solid.
Alice: 放上边吧
Alice: Put it on top.
Lucia: 哎我还以为我一直连着电线呢
Lucia: Oh, I thought I was still connected to the wire.
Lucia: 居然没有
Lucia: Turns out I'm not.
Jake: 好那就趁机充个电
Jake: Alright, let's take the chance to charge it up.
Lucia: 哎有道理
Lucia: Oh, makes sense.
Lucia: 先把它连上
Lucia: Let's connect it first.
Alice: 怎么会把它放在这里面呢
Alice: How did it end up in here?
Alice: 我们是买了两个金针菇还是一个呀
Alice: Did we buy two enoki mushrooms or just one?
Tasha: 一个好像
Tasha: I think just one.
Alice:一个
Alice: Just one.
Tasha: 一袋
Tasha: One bag.
Alice:一个吗
Alice: Just one?
Alice: 嗯是呢
Alice: Hmm, yeah.
Alice: 算了就这样吧
Alice: Never mind, let's just go with it.
Alice: 我怎么会把
Alice: Why did I put
Alice: 皮蛋放冷冻呢
Alice: the century egg in the freezer?
小汾：花好香啊
Katrina: The flowers smell so good.
Katrina:  到底是哪种花香
Katrina: What kind of flowers are these?
Alice: 开始吧
Alice: Let's start.
Alice: 找一下盆
Alice: Find a basin.
Alice:解冻一下
Alice: Thaw it a bit.
Alice: 刀
Alice: Knife.
Alice:嗯嗯
Alice: Mm-hmm.
Alice: 锅在哪
Alice: Where's the pot?
Alice: 怎么还要自己刷这个呀
Alice: Why do I have to wash this myself?
Tasha: 掉出来了掉出来了
Tasha: It fell out, it fell out.
Alice: 哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
Alice: 就这个吧
Alice: Let's go with this one.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh man.
Alice: 定了咣当的
Alice: It's really loud.
Jake: 我去一把大菜刀
Jake: I'll go get a big cleaver.
Jake: 这菜刀是不是不够
Jake: Is this cleaver not enough?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake: 这菜刀是不是不够锋利呀
Jake: Is this kitchen knife not sharp enough?
Alice: 切个白菜无所谓
Alice: It's fine for cutting cabbage.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Alice: 不太想让我的戒指沾水
Alice: I don't really want my ring to get wet.
Alice: 说实话我要给它去下来了
Alice: Honestly, I'm going to take it off.
Alice: 给你个神圣的职责照看他一下
Alice: I'm giving you a sacred duty to watch over it.
Alice: 这锅几百年没刷了
Alice: This pot hasn't been scrubbed for centuries.
Alice: 说实话这个锅没有很大
Alice: To be honest, this pot isn't very big.
Alice:噔噔噔 噔噔噔噔噔
Alice: Dun dun dun dun dun dun dun
Alice: 菜板
Alice: Cutting board.
Alice:撕
Alice: Tear
Alice: 这个也不能沾水
Alice: This can't get wet either.
Alice: 你帮我去掉一下
Alice: Can you help me take it off?
Tasha: 是这样吗
Tasha: Like this?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Jake: 你在切啥
Jake: What are you cutting?
Tasha: 加三次糖
Tasha: Add sugar three times.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my.
Tasha: 不记得了
Tasha: Can't remember.
Tasha: 呃不是不
Tasha: Uh, no.
Tasha: 记得了具体的配方
Tasha: I remember the exact recipe.
Alice: 我先把你这个放一边了啊
Alice: I'll put this aside for now.
Tasha: 找蛋戳
Tasha: Find the egg piercer.
Tasha: 这个这个心OK
Tasha: This, this heart is okay.
Tasha: 就这样
Tasha: Just like this.
Tasha: 然后烤箱温度记一下子
Tasha: Then note the oven temperature.
Alice: 哎呦我的天
Alice: Oh my god.
Alice: 真够危险
Alice: That's really dangerous.
Tasha: OK
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun dun dun
Tasha: can you help me
Tasha: Can you help me?
Jake: yes
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: yes
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 呃我的无菌手套呢
Tasha: Uh, where are my sterile gloves?
Tasha: 被谁呢拿到哪里去了
Tasha: Who took them and where?
Jake: 你的什么
Jake: Your what?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Tasha: 哦在这里
Tasha: Oh, here they are.
Tasha: police and me take this
Tasha: Police and me take this.
Alice: 松花蛋在哪里
Alice: Where is the century egg?
Jake: 松花蛋OK
Jake: Century egg, OK.
Alice:松花蛋
Alice: Century egg.
Tasha: 松花蛋在这里在在
Tasha: The century egg is here.
Alice: 哦ok
Alice: Oh, okay.
Jake:帮你
Jake: I'll help you.
Katrina: 有啥要要我帮忙的不
Katrina: Do you need any help?
Katrina:  嗯i can我已经free了
Katrina: Hmm, I can help, I'm free now.
Jake:好滴
Jake: Okay.
Katrina:  我看看我这压花
Katrina: Let me check my flower press.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina:  这两天能压出什么东西
Katrina: Let's see what I can press in these two days.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  先尝试一个
Katrina: I'll try one first.
Jake: 你要你你你是你你
Jake: You, you, you, you.
Katrina:  我已经压了一个
Katrina: I've already pressed one.
Jake: 你要在地上压还是最好有个桌子还是
Jake: Are you pressing it on the floor? It's better to use a table.
Katrina:  不是我那个板
Katrina: No, my board.
Katrina:  就是那个压花板
Katrina: It's the flower press board.
Katrina:  我已经放了几片花瓣进去了
Katrina: I've already put some petals inside.
Katrina:  不知道压出来什么效果
Katrina: Not sure what the result will be.
Katrina:  它不是也要两三天吗
Katrina: It takes two or three days, right?
Jake: 哦哦就就是你你一直在地上压这个是不是
Jake: Oh, oh, so you've been pressing it on the floor, right?
Jake: 嗯伤腰啊呵呵
Jake: Hmm, it's bad for your back, haha.
Katrina:  没事年轻的
Katrina: It's fine, I'm young.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈好嘞
Jake: Hahaha, alright.
Tasha: 他在说你
Tasha: He's talking about you.
Jake: 对确实
Jake: Yes, indeed.
Katrina:  今天下午坐地上插了花然后也压了
Katrina: This afternoon I sat on the floor arranging flowers and also pressed them.
Jake: 哎你要哪个
Jake: Hey, which one do you want?
Tasha: 哦我有我其实
Tasha: Oh, I actually...
Tasha: 好吧那你不带也行
Tasha: Fine, you don't need to bring it.
Jake:不要了
Jake: I don't need it.
Tasha: 你不用了
Tasha: You don't need it?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 哎哎求助一下
Alice: Hey, hey, I need some help.
Jake:好你你看我我能干这个
Jake: Okay, you see, I can do this.
Jake: 对来吧来吧来吧
Jake: Yeah, come on, come on, come on.
Alice:算了
Alice: Never mind.
Tasha: 我一开始是想让你也带一双的
Tasha: I initially wanted you to bring a pair too.
Jake: 哦我以为你帮我
Jake: Oh, I thought you were helping me.
Jake: 你让我稍薇
Jake: You're making me wait a bit longer.
Alice: OK了thank you
Alice: 你可真难出来呀兄弟
Alice: It's really hard to get you out, buddy.
Tasha: 哎我刚刚的那个大的那个盆呢
Tasha: Hey, where's that big basin I just had?
Alice:盆
Alice: The basin.
Tasha: 大的那个盆
Tasha: The big one.
Alice: 我给你搁那了
Alice: I put it over there for you.
Alice: 是那个吧
Alice: Is it that one?
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Alice:我刀呢
Alice: Where's my knife?
Alice: 没洗呢
Alice: It's not washed yet.
Tasha: 天呐这
Tasha: Oh my gosh, this...
Alice: 怎么了
Alice: What's up?
Tasha: 餐巾纸
Tasha: Napkins.
Jake: 有得等一下我先
Jake: Hold on, we need to wait a bit.
Alice:有点大呀
Alice: It's a bit big.
Alice:太小了
Alice: It's too small.
Alice:有这够我们几个人吃吗
Alice: Will this be enough for all of us?
Tasha: 够吧
Tasha: Should be enough.
Alice:够吗
Alice: Really?
Tasha: 够了吧
Tasha: It should be enough.
Alice:要不吧这半也切进去吧
Alice: How about we cut this half as well?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Tasha: 行咱在也不会不标昨夜吃
Tasha: Sure, we won't regret it later.
Alice:因为还有块午餐肉
Alice: Because there's still some luncheon meat.
Tasha: 撕 完了完了啊
Tasha: Oh no, it's torn.
Alice:啊呀
Alice: Ah!
Alice:炒鸡蛋吧没关系的宝宝
Alice: Let's just make scrambled eggs, it's okay, babe.
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: It's ruined.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice:没关系的宝贝
Alice: It's okay, sweetheart.
Alice: 没关系没关系这个蛋就炒鸡蛋吧
Alice: It's fine, it's fine, we'll just make scrambled eggs with this.
Tasha: 你这个里面需要蛋花吗
Tasha: Do you need egg flowers in this?
Alice: 那倒不需要
Alice: No, we don't need that.
Tasha: 那怎么办
Tasha: Then what should we do?
Alice:啧
Alice: Ugh.
Alice: 这是个问题
Alice: That's a problem.
Alice: 摆烂了是吗
Alice: Are you giving up?
Tasha: 想摆烂了受不了了
Tasha: I'm thinking about giving up, can't take it anymore.
Tasha: 失败了
Tasha: Failed.
Alice:你喜欢吃午餐肉吗
Alice: Do you like eating luncheon meat?
Tasha: 还好
Tasha: It's okay.
Alice:还好是
Alice: Okay, so...
Tasha: 鸡蛋
Tasha: Eggs.
Alice:多好
Alice: Nice.
Tasha: 那我就放到这个里面了
Tasha: Then I'll put it in here.
Alice:啊啊啊你要干嘛
Alice: Ah, ah, ah, what are you doing?
Tasha: 放进去
Tasha: Putting it in.
Alice:你放那里面干嘛
Alice: Why are you putting it in there?
Tasha: 不知道
Tasha: Don't know.
Alice:天哪
Alice: Oh my god.
Tasha: 用不上哦酷
Tasha: Not useful, oh cool.
Alice:大摆烂
Alice: Big mess.
Alice:这个午餐肉
Alice: This luncheon meat...
Alice:有点略薇的多了
Alice: There's a bit too much of it.
Alice:不过没关系
Alice: But that's okay.
Alice: give me一个碗
Alice: Give me a bowl.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice: 没有人在吗我想让人帮我问个算了我来吧
Alice: Is anyone here? I want someone to help me. Never mind, I'll do it myself.
Katrina: 我帮你想想
Katrina: I'll help you think.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Alice:我需要一点热水
Alice: I need some hot water.
Alice:就是那个
Alice: Just that.
Katrina: 我帮你烧一壶开水
Katrina: I'll boil a pot of water for you.
Alice:对比较多的
Alice: Yeah, a lot of it.
Tasha: 你来帮我吗
Tasha: Can you help me?
Alice:多多两
Alice: More, more...
Alice: 呃两升左右
Alice: About two liters.
Tasha: 谢谢你
Tasha: Thank you.
Katrina: 这是多少
Katrina: How much is this?
Tasha: 这因为我现在遇到了一个难题
Tasha: Because I'm facing a problem right now.
Alice: 没关系多了也没事
Alice: It's okay, even if it's too much.
Lucia: 让我来
Lucia: Let me do it.
Katrina: 这应该没有两升
Katrina: This probably isn't two liters.
Lucia: 我要上去换个衣服
Lucia: I need to go change clothes.
Alice:额不够也行
Alice: It's okay if it's not enough.
Lucia: 够也行就是跟那个裙子袖子很长
Lucia: Enough or not, the sleeves of that dress are too long.
Lucia: 感觉做饭不方便
Lucia: It's inconvenient for cooking.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 做甜品的话最重要的就是无油无水
Tasha: The most important thing when making desserts is no oil and no water.
Tasha: 所以所有的盆都要把擦干
Tasha: So you need to dry all the bowls.
Lucia: 啊 OK
Lucia: Ah, OK.
Tasha: 擦的一滴水都没有
Tasha: Make sure there's not a drop of water.
Lucia: 啊  好的 没问题
Lucia: Ah, got it, no problem.
Katrina:  这是做什么汤来着
Katrina: What soup are we making again?
Tasha: 不然会导致打发不出来
Tasha: Otherwise, it won't whip properly.
Alice:酸汤娃娃菜
Alice: Sour soup with baby cabbage.
Katrina: 如果是那个汤菜吗
Katrina: Is it that kind of soup?
Lucia: 呃那我也要带一个这种一次性手套吗
Lucia: Uh, should I wear these disposable gloves too?
Alice:是南方那边的虽然我不是个南方人但我比较喜欢那种鲜一点的汤
Alice: It's from the south. Although I'm not from there, I really like the fresh flavor of the soup.
Tasha: 可以不带
Tasha: You don't need to.
Tasha: 对不用带
Tasha: Yeah, no need.
Lucia: 哦行那我先去把手洗一下再
Lucia: Oh, alright, I'll go wash my hands first.
Tasha: 呃你洗了手之后要把手擦干
Tasha: Uh, after you wash your hands, make sure to dry them.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Got it.
Lucia: 先放个衣服然后搭把手帮我
Lucia: First, put on some clothes and then lend me a hand.
Alice: 外国人会见过这种蛋吗
Alice: Do foreigners know about this kind of egg?
Alice: 他们是不是觉得这种蛋是一种比较
Alice: Don't they think this kind of egg is a bit...
Lucia: 我这个还亮着 所以还在录吧
Lucia: This is still on, so it's recording, right?
Alice: 异类的东西
Alice: ...strange?
Katrina:  都会觉得这发霉了
Katrina: They all think it's moldy.
Alice: 这其实是一种很好吃的蛋
Alice: Actually, this is a really delicious egg.
Alice: 屏幕前的朋友们
Alice: Friends in front of the screen,
Alice: 如果你们有机会来中国的话
Alice: if you ever get the chance to come to China,
小汾：外国的
Katrina: Foreigners...
Alice: 我希望你们
Alice: I hope you...
Alice:可以
Alice: 希望拨出一个比较好看的蛋
Alice: ...try to pick a good-looking egg.
Alice: 哦不错
Alice: Oh, nice.
Alice: this is a
Alice: This is a...
Alice: good 蛋哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: ...good egg, hahaha.
Katrina: 在说什么啦
Katrina: What are you talking about?
Alice:哎呀 哎呀
Alice: Oh dear, oh dear.
Tasha: 已经放置了
Tasha: It's already placed.
Tasha: 哦哦
Tasha: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 不不我要把手先擦一下
Lucia: No, no, I need to dry my hands first.
Katrina:  对打鸡蛋吗
Katrina: So we're beating the egg?
Tasha: 呃先把盆擦一下
Tasha: Uh, first dry the bowl.
Tasha: 然后再打鸡蛋
Tasha: Then beat the egg.
Tasha: 稍等把鸡蛋给他喝
Tasha: Hold on, give him the egg to drink.
Tasha: 对就是我碰无菌的东西
Tasha: Yes, I handle the sterile stuff.
Tasha: 你碰有菌的东西
Tasha: You handle the non-sterile stuff.
Tasha: 这样子我们就可以保证食材的干净
Tasha: This way we can ensure the ingredients are clean.
Lucia: 哎这个桶能恢复正常吗
Lucia: Hey, can this bucket be fixed?
Alice:两个四个可能不太够再加一两个
Alice: Two or four might not be enough, let's add one or two more.
Alice:可能需要
Alice: We might need to...
Alice:回温一下下
Alice: Warm it up a bit.
Alice:因为这个不小心放进了冷冻 冷冻的切不动哎呀妈呀
Alice: Because it accidentally got frozen, and you can't cut frozen stuff, oh my gosh.
Alice:所以让他解冻好自己带解说的
Alice: So let it thaw and it will explain itself.
Alice:自带解说
Alice: It explains itself.
Tasha: 帮我也洗个碗呗
Tasha: Could you wash a dish for me too?
Lucia: 这个盆是他们民宿这的吗
Lucia: Is this basin from their guesthouse?
Alice:给 宝
Alice: Here, dear.
Tasha: 我买的
Tasha: I bought it.
Lucia: 哦哦我说怎么会有这么
Lucia: Oh, I was wondering why it looks so...
Tasha:先进的碗
Tasha: Advanced.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Right.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh dear.
Katrina:  哇有花的房间就是不一样但是挺好看的
Katrina: Wow, a room with flowers is really different, but it's quite nice.
Alice:我希望他不要糖心他一糠心他就会流的那都是
Alice: I hope it doesn't bleed, if it bleeds, it will all come out.
Lucia: 杯蛋
Lucia: Egg in a cup.
Alice:这个好软呀
Alice: This is so soft.
Alice:哎
Alice: Hey.
Tasha: 你能打下下一个吗
Tasha: Can you crack the next one?
Tasha: 我这手有点黏糊了
Tasha: My hands are a bit sticky.
Lucia: 没问题
Lucia: No problem.
Tasha: 一定要打的很低
Tasha: Make sure to crack it low.
Alice:这个灯
Alice: This light...
Tasha: 他就不会散开
Tasha: So it doesn't spread.
Lucia: 打的很低
Lucia: Crack it low.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh dear.
Tasha: 啊啊坏了
Tasha: Ah, it's ruined.
Tasha: 呃重做了
Tasha: Uh, redo it.
Tasha: 要重新打蛋了
Tasha: We need to crack the egg again.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Alice: 有我们今天是不是得吃炒鸡蛋了宝
Alice: Are we having scrambled eggs today, dear?
Tasha: 嗯他不
Tasha: Hmm, it won't...
Tasha: 他要打的很低才行啊
Tasha: It needs to be cracked really low.
Lucia: 要多我我觉得这样
Lucia: We need more, I think.
Lucia: 因为我感觉再往下
Lucia: Because I feel if we go lower,
Lucia: 好像蛋壳会碰到这个
Lucia: it seems like the eggshell will touch this.
Lucia: 蛋清嗯嗯
Lucia: The egg white, hmm hmm.
Tasha: 流出来就失败了哦
Tasha: If it leaks out, it's a failure.
Lucia: 啊这为什么
Lucia: Ah, why is that?
Katrina:  为什么嗯
Katrina: Why, hmm?
Tasha: 蛋清蛋黄不能分离了哦
Tasha: The egg white and yolk can't be separated.
Katrina:  你买那个就是分离蛋清
Katrina: You bought that thing to separate the egg whites.
Tasha: 分离蛋清气不好用
Tasha: The egg white separator isn't good.
Katrina:  哦我之前看那个综艺谁
Katrina: Oh, I saw that show where someone...
Katrina:  我也不太会打蛋了
Katrina: I don't know how to crack eggs either.
Tasha: 好那下一次吧
Tasha: Okay, let's do it next time.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Alice: 又又又又变成这个了
Alice: It's turned into this again.
Tasha:: 呃我算了
Tasha: Uh, forget it.
Alice: 没关系宝贝
Alice: It's okay, babe.
Katrina:  哇好像个实验台
Katrina: Wow, it looks like a lab table.
Lucia: 那我们这个
Lucia: So, this...
Lucia: 哈哈这个蛋蛋他怎么办
Lucia: Haha, what should we do with this egg?
Lucia: 要不炒了吧
Lucia: How about we fry it?
Alice: 炒蛋吧
Alice: Let's fry it.
Katrina:  本来要做成什么
Katrina: What were we going to make originally?
Tasha: 做蛋糕
Tasha: A cake.
Alice:蛋糕
Alice: A cake.
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Alice:没关系蛋糕也是蛋
Alice: It's okay, a cake is still made of eggs.
Tasha: 拿一个小饮料
Tasha: Grab a drink.
Katrina:  哎呀牛奶怎翻了
Katrina: Oh no, the milk spilled!
Tasha: 下一个鸡蛋
Tasha: Next egg.
Lucia: 下一个鸡蛋在哪
Lucia: Where's the next egg?
Tasha: 两个在那里
Tasha: There are two there.
Tasha: 在那里哪个
Tasha: Which one?
Lucia: 呃这里面
Lucia: Uh, in here.
Lucia: 哦OK
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈哈惨遭滑铁卢的经验
Katrina: Hahaha, such a Waterloo experience.
Alice:屏幕前的家人们不要觉得这个切得很恶心这都不重要无所谓的
Alice: Family in front of the screen, don't think this looks disgusting, it doesn't matter at all.
Lucia: 磕丹磕丹磕得太用力了
Lucia: Cracked the egg too hard.
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia: 那我们先
Lucia: So, let's...
Katrina: 炒吧
Katrina: Stir-fry it.
Lucia: 无所谓把那个把那个午餐肉喝了
Lucia: Doesn't matter, just drink that luncheon meat soup.
Alice:这就是为什么我不想要太软的
Alice: That's why I don't want it too soft.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哎
Tasha: Hahaha, oh man.
Lucia: 啊里面的午餐肉呢
Lucia: Ah, where's the luncheon meat?
Lucia: 我们是做别的菜用了吗
Lucia: Did we use it for another dish?
Alice:糖心的原因因为他切起来会比较恶心
Alice: The reason for the sugar center is that it's gross to cut.
Alice: 是吗到了外面去
Alice: Really? Did it go outside?
Katrina:  哎所以我们刚才点点点外卖了吗
Katrina: So, did we just order takeout?
Alice:但是呢如果不够糖心的话他就会比较硬
Alice: But if it's not sweet enough, it'll be too hard.
Tasha: 点了
Tasha: We did.
Lucia: 点了的话那今天再炒个蛋
Lucia: If we did, let's fry another egg today.
Lucia: 能吃完不
Lucia: Can we finish it?
Lucia: 要不我把这蛋给他炒了算了
Lucia: Should I just fry this egg?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:因为比较硬
Alice: Because it's too hard.
Tasha: 简直不敢相信
Tasha: I can't believe it.
Alice:没有那么香
Alice: It's not that fragrant.
Tasha: 我要是你你
Tasha: If I were you...
Lucia: 那你需要换个手套或者之类的吗
Lucia: Do you need to change gloves or something?
Alice: 好的家人们下一步了
Alice: Alright, family, next step.
Tasha: 我的
Tasha: My...
Alice:怎么自带解说呢
Alice: Why do you come with your own commentary?
Lucia: 哈哈i'm Libbo
Lucia: Haha, I'm Libbo.
Lucia: 虽然我拿了
Lucia: Even though I took it...
Lucia: 多少蛋啊
Lucia: How many eggs did I take?
Alice:;没关系摆烂了怎么是一个糖心的呢
Alice: It's okay, giving up, how is this a sugar center?
Lucia: 两盒吗不知道
Lucia: Two boxes? Not sure.
Lucia: 好像是两盒
Lucia: Seems like two boxes.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 做做那个小蛋糕应该还
Lucia: Making those small cakes should be fine.
Alice:;哎切皮蛋真是一个恶心人的过程但是不重要重要的是他真的很鲜很香
Alice: Cutting century eggs is such a gross process but it's not important, what's important is that it's really fresh and fragrant.
Lucia: 哈哈不敢相信
Lucia: Haha, can't believe it.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Tasha: 完了这个蛋清额这个也多了
Tasha: Oh no, the egg white, uh, this too much.
Lucia: 好了那个
Lucia: Okay, that...
Lucia: 那样的话没有问题吗
Lucia: Is that okay?
Tasha: 嗯对蛋黄里面
Tasha: Yeah, in the egg yolk.
Tasha: 没关系蛋蛋清里面一定要是纯蛋清
Tasha: It's okay, the egg white has to be pure egg white.
Tasha: 嗯行再拿两个
Tasha: Okay, let's get two more.
Lucia: 额哈哈哈
Lucia: Uh hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Alice:我们今天一共买了多少蛋呀
Alice: How many eggs did we buy today?
Tasha: 嗯好吧我们下次买便宜蛋吧哈哈
Tasha: Hmm okay, let's buy cheaper eggs next time, haha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Alice: 没关系的
Alice: It's okay.
Tasha: 没关系，今天肯定是第一次
Tasha: It's okay, today is definitely the first time.
Katrina:  哇哦
Katrina: Wow
Katrina:  又成功了
Katrina: It worked again.
Tasha: 不敢相信
Tasha: Can't believe it.
Tasha: 好厉害
Tasha: Amazing.
Alice:好我在重复一次
Alice: Okay, I'll repeat it again.
Alice: 不要觉得这个切的很恶心
Alice: Don't think this chopping is gross.
Alice: 我看我老妈做的也是这样的
Alice: I've seen my mom do it like this too.
Alice: 我妈做皮蛋瘦肉粥很好喝但是他切
Alice: My mom makes really good century egg and lean pork congee but when she chops
Katrina:  我超级喜欢吃皮蛋瘦肉粥
Katrina: I love century egg and lean pork congee.
Alice: 但是他切皮蛋的时候也是像现在一样恶心我曾经看过的
Alice: But when she chops the century egg, it's as gross as it is now. I've seen it before.
Alice: 好这就是我的个人自言自语时刻
Alice: Okay, this is my personal monologue moment.
Katrina:  你可以拍一个第一视角的vlog
Katrina: You could make a first-person vlog.
Alice: yes
Alice: Yes.
Tasha: 把这个拿到冰箱里面
Tasha: Put this in the fridge.
Tasha: 呃楼上冰箱吧
Tasha: Uh, the upstairs fridge.
Tasha: 因为这已经放不下了
Tasha: Because this one is already full.
Tasha: 冷冻10分钟
Tasha: Freeze it for 10 minutes.
Alice:呀啊啊
Alice: Ahhh
Tasha: 冷藏10分钟
Tasha: Chill it for 10 minutes.
Lucia: 冷藏10分钟
Lucia: Chill it for 10 minutes.
Alice:哎说实话整个菜的过程中我比较讨厌就是切这个皮蛋因为他真嘟很恶心
Alice: To be honest, the part I hate most about this dish is chopping the century egg because it's really gross.
Tasha: 就可以OK了
Tasha: That should be okay.
Tasha: 额呵呵呵
Tasha: Uh hehehe
Alice:不是假嘟很恶心
Alice: Seriously, it's really gross.
Alice:我觉得我挺适合当博主的因为我
Alice: I think I'd make a good blogger because I
Tasha: 是的你很爱自言自语是吗
Tasha: Yeah, you love talking to yourself, right?
Alice:;是的
Alice: Yes.
Alice:我现在很很害怕到时候看到这个得外国人会觉得我在做黑暗料理
Alice: I'm really afraid that when foreigners see this, they'll think I'm making some kind of dark cuisine.
Alice: 现在的工具还没有能到达通过屏幕就可以尝到的那种
Alice: The current technology hasn't reached the point where you can taste through the screen.
Alice:;如果让他们亲口尝一下他们肯定会改变这个看法的家人们他真的很好吃相信我
Alice: If they could taste it themselves, they would definitely change their mind. Guys, it really tastes good, believe me.
Alice:我真的解释了很多遍他真的很好吃
Alice: I've explained many times, it really tastes good.
Alice:随便吧
Alice: Whatever.
Alice:逐渐暴躁起来了
Alice: I'm getting more and more frustrated.
Alice:哎讨厌切皮蛋
Alice: Ugh, I hate cutting century eggs.
Tasha: 居然不够用了
Tasha: We're actually out of it.
Alice:啥呀
Alice: What?
Lucia: 哦他有这个东西
Lucia: Oh, he has this thing.
Alice:啥东西呀
Alice: What thing?
Lucia: 哎放着吧
Lucia: Just leave it there.
Katrina: 搅鸡蛋有什么技巧
Katrina: Any tips for beating eggs?
Tasha: 额搅鸡蛋没有什么技巧
Tasha: Uh, there's no special trick to it.
Alice:就同一个方向顺 同一个分=方向搅就行了
Alice: Just stir it in the same direction, that's it.
Tasha: 额等一下吧
Tasha: Uh, let's wait a bit.
Alice:你说讨厌红楼梦里你想那么多
Alice: You said you hate Dream of the Red Chamber, why think so much about it?
Tasha: ok擦干呵呵
Tasha: Okay, wipe it dry, haha.
Lucia: 再擦一遍
Lucia: Wipe it again.
Tasha:: 对因为只有一个对吧自己扭一下
Tasha: Yeah, because there's only one, right? Just twist it yourself.
Alice:其实做菜的时候真的没有很慢主要就是备菜的过程及后续刷碗洗完的过程
Alice: Actually, cooking isn't really slow. It's mainly the prep and the cleanup that take time.
Tasha: 所以呃
Tasha: So, uh...
Tasha: 所以如果做烘焙的话
Tasha: So if you're baking...
Tasha: 会买那种厨房用纸
Tasha: You should get those kitchen towels.
Tasha: 可以擦干很多遍的那个
Tasha: The ones that can absorb a lot.
Lucia: 额就是那个吸吸吸水纸那种对
Lucia: Uh, like those super absorbent ones, right?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 这是啥
Tasha: What's this?
Lucia: 我以前光光拿那个擦过澡原来
Lucia: I used to use that to dry myself off, actually.
Katrina: 你这是要做什么来着
Katrina: What are you making again?
Tasha: 就小蛋糕
Tasha: Just a small cake.
Tasha: 就做一个就行呗
Tasha: Just making one, it's fine.
Tasha: 打鸡蛋
Tasha: Beat the eggs.
Tasha: 先煮饭
Tasha: Cook the rice first.
Alice:逐渐暴躁我真的讨厌切皮蛋啊
Alice: Getting irritated, I really hate cutting century eggs.
Alice:谁给能给我一个筷子啊就这样吧就这样吧
Alice: Can someone give me a pair of chopsticks? Just like this, just like this.
Alice:好保持平静心情平静
Alice: Okay, stay calm, stay calm.
Katrina: 这个是叫蛋花
Katrina: This is called egg drop.
Tasha: 对用蛋黄
Tasha: Yeah, using the egg yolk.
Lucia: 好像应该我觉得差不多了
Lucia: I think it's probably done.
Tasha: 我们外面应该煮一下
Tasha: We should probably boil it outside.
Alice:你说讨厌红楼梦里啧恶心
Alice: You said you hate Dream of the Red Chamber, ugh, disgusting. 社会问题
Tasha: 放歌吧
Tasha: Let's play some music.
Alice:大东北
Alice: Northeast songs.
Lucia: 我知道咱们唱的这个歌新版红楼梦
Lucia: I know, the ones from the new version of Dream of the Red Chamber.
Alice:对对对哎呀天呐受不了了
Alice: Yeah, yeah, oh my god, I can't stand it.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Alice:讨厌红楼梦
Alice: I hate "Dream of the Red Chamber"
Lucia: 你说讨厌红楼梦
Lucia: You said you hate "Dream of the Red Chamber"?